le résultat de la primaire a été un
résultat qui était un résultat qui
entraîné vraiment très à gauche le parti
socialiste est aussi qui a donné aux
candidats une responsabilité très forte
et la responsabilité qu'il avait c'était
de dire mais voilà si je veux être le
candidat du rassemblement a entériné 2
fait l'explosion de la gauche ou de
cette de gauches irréconciliables
ces deux causes absolues je crois que au
lieu de rassembler largement la primaire
en fait à accélérer une division qui qui
existaient déjà et qui est qu'il a est
devenu un petit peu absolument visible
et voilà donc moi je ne reproche pas à
benoît hamon de ne pas avoir réussi à
rassembler tout le monde même si c'était
l'engagement des primaires parce qu'on
parle d'engagement tenue d'un côté il
faut les tenir des deux côtés benoît
hamon avait pris l'engagement de
rassembler tous les candidats à la
primaire autour d'un projet autour du
sien puisque ça et tel-aviv est connue
mais en donnant des en donnant des
signes en essayant de voir ce qu'ils
avaient dans le programme des autres
qu'ils pouvaient être pris ça il ne l'a
pas fait avec toute une liste des
candidats c'est une erreur après est ce
que est ce que c'était possible
vu la situation je lui laisse le
bénéfice du doute franchement c'était
peut-être pas évident mais defacto le
fait qu'ils partent vers mélenchon qui
partent verts cécile duflot ça a
vraiment créé une division encore plus
forte
et quand on voit d'ailleurs les
résultats de cette démarche qui fait que
même si les sondages ne sont pas l'alpha
et l'oméga le fait qu'ils baisent qu'ils
baisent qu'il baisse dans les sondages
montrent que ce travail de rassemblement
qu'il devait faire n'a pas été fait